you
[Music]
today I'm gonna talk about how to
optimize time to data through streams
and data abstractions and there's a like
a bunch of AI in the sauce to be able to
do that so before actually talking about
this let me introduce myself a little
bit so my name is Nikki I'm like the VP
entering and she I saw a data log before
doing that I worked at several startups
I co-founded and was CTO of startup
called get links that was doing risk
management software for open source
software what also worked at the French
DoD in security and gratis recent grab
his realization software troubling
curious
I was fronting lead there but let's deep
dive a little bit more into dialogue and
how we measure and optimize them to data
so why measure and optimize the data we
believe that there's a universal truth
which is like every like Enterprise is
trying to become a data-driven
enterprise and that's like that kind of
like been existing forever because
company actually have been using Excel
for quite some time and they they've
been doing like quarterly schedule on
Excel and taking data in and making
predictions these kind of things so it's
like not something that's very new but
it's the extending beyond just
financials it's like using CRM data
trying to like consolidate all that data
into data late to try to actually do
something about it
so basically what they're trying to do
is like a manufacturing plant getting
data in doing something with it like a
process like to change it and then
starting analyzing it with analytics
tools and then producing a decision out
of it so it's very much throughout the
talk I'm gonna draw a parallel between
manufacturing and like data engineering
which I think are very very similar so
in that Lance see the time that it takes
for you to take a decision and be
decomposed into two
things first thing is the time that it
takes for you to get the logistics of
the data so figure out how to transfer
it around get in on the system to run
your analytics like all those things
which is just a pain but you have to do
and then running your analytics on the
top of the data what we do at dialogue
is optimize the time to data so we make
your logistics super easy for you to get
the data where you actually need it so
basically what you're doing is they take
that big pile of mess and like
streamlining it to put it somewhere
useful and during the talk I'm also
going to draw a parallel with one of our
customer use case so here what you can
see is like quite interesting it's a
Wi-Fi access point data that's happening
live during their hurricane the last
hurricane that we saw so that's a talent
telecommunication customer and what they
want is to be able to have that this
relation the reason why it's important
is because they want to be able to send
the maintenance workers to write
locations to be able to restore
connectivity and connectivity is super
important because it's used by
first-time responders to be able to
answer calls also for from like people
to be able to know from which route to
get out of a 418 zone so super critical
to have near real-time data and good
data to be able to draw this
visualization so this is right before
the hurricane it's like the this is
right after so you can see like hey
everything is going down so this is like
really super important for them so in
order to to get to those things I'm
gonna start by beating in the whole
course with like manufacturing lean
manufacturing principles and see how we
can apply those things to to actually
time to data and how to
prove that that's that like process so
the first thing I think you all have
heard about agile methodologies and how
like working progress is the root of all
evil
so you really need to find like those
steps that are too big before we drive
value so the same way with agile is for
data it's like what you want is like do
a little bit of a work like shape it a
little bit of a work shape it do a
little bit of a work ship it and not
like hey I'm gonna wait a week do all my
work you do a big process and then maybe
in a week I will have a thing or not if
I screwed something up and then I need
to start again so every working progress
same thing root of all evil so the way
we do this is through two things float
immunization so how do you really take
your data and like streamlining it to
where you need it and how do the user
also like has a good flow to interact
with the data so getting feedback look
very fast is really important so that
you don't end up with a feedback loop
that's really so so for example spark
you have to compile a program you have
to deploy it and you start getting
feedback when you're late to start again
it takes forever and it takes like so
much time so flow optimization is very
important and just-in-time delivery is
the second thing that's super important
so as soon as you able to press start
processing data you should start process
your data right away so that you have
the first results and you can start
having visualization even though it's
not the most accurate then like the
accuracy is like building up as you get
more data so in order to walk through
those different type of things I'm gonna
go back to the manufacturing kind of
analogy and talk about how the Bill of
Materials is relevant to all this so
before we start I didn't know what the
Bill of Materials was I'm gonna explain
to you what it is so that we're all on
the same page
the it's essentially an inventory of
everything that you put in the car all
right
that you built it's not only what you
put in the carpet it's also the
transformations all like the processes
that's that aren't there so if you have
a wheel and like a tire the process of
putting the tire on the will and will be
within the Bill of Materials right so in
terms of data that's about the same
thing
so in our use case of telecommunication
data where we want to have a live stream
of where all the access points matter
alive and which are the one that are not
live what you want to be able to do is
take one source of data which is going
to be a access point with MAC address a
is life and then you have another source
of data which holds the longitude and
latitude of the data of your like access
point so what you need to do is be able
to join those data on the fly while the
events are coming in and then being able
to have that result data assets that's
actually something that you can use to
build your visualization so Bill of
material describes two things the
components of your data and then the
transformations that you apply to it so
we're going to dive into those two
aspects on how we can optimize them to
reduce the time that it takes for you to
actually get your data where you need it
so first is sourcing all the types of
material that you need so as a
manufacturer I'm gonna have to build my
car I'm gonna source things from like
Ericsson for example for my electronics
lid and then you will have another
supplier for your tires and like wheels
or for your body like every type of like
source of material is gonna be different
and so likes manufacturers they found
they find they're like raw materials
across a wide area
you have suppliers and for data driven
businesses it's exactly the same way so
if you just drive value from a one file
that's being like I'd put it
from whatever system like a CRM it's
probably like a little value but a
little and then if you start like
cross-referencing it with some others
type of sources that's because there's a
business that starts being more
interesting and the more source of data
you actually agreed it the more
interesting things become so data-driven
businesses they drive value from a wide
variety of sources but what if we could
abstract this away so right now like for
supplier having a wide range of supply
for a manufacturer having a wide range
of suppliers
it makes things difficult and complex
same thing for data sources like when
you have a wide variety of sources makes
things difficult and complex so what we
do is model that thing and if you model
that thing in a way where you have like
n sources and then destination roughly
you're going to have n square
combinations to like build pipelines
between every source and every
destination type that you want basically
this is it's just if you want to cut the
stuff if you want to start transforming
your data and you're like expanding a
little bit like that space and that
becomes even more complex so what we do
at dialogue and now I'm getting a little
bit more in the meat of like the tech is
that we put something in the middle the
same way the LLVM is putting in the
intermediate representation to be able
to compile to several target system so
like to explain that a little bit more
so languages that are comp natively
compiled there's a back-end quality the
LLVM
and that back-end is like a standard
representation all languages compiled to
something standard and then you have
like machine code for each one of the
architecture here but it's the same
thing but on data so the idea is that
you have encoders and decoders that are
going to lift the representation from
something very concrete so JSON
Cassandra you call this kind of things
to a graph a series of graph and then
you do your work on those graphs so now
you don't need to
have scripts for tabular data scripts
for late tree-like data strips of JSON
script for CSV you just have your script
for ad DS then you can plug that onto
any source or destination but you're
interested in the the way jdg works is
very very simple like there's nothing
more simple than this it's a directed
graph with two properties label and
value that value can be optional and
it's typed so like the types are things
like strings boolean's integers loads
all those kind of things and with this
data structure we able to abstract away
pretty much like anything that comes in
so this is like handling the first layer
of abstraction that we talked about the
first layer of variants which is a as
data engineer I want to be able to get
data from Postgres from like [ __ ] from
MS sequel and I don't want to lose time
rewriting the same scripts all over
again what if we could also abstract
another layer within that stack which is
the semantic types so this is where the
machine running comes in and this is
where the intelligence is really once
you have the data the data can still be
structured in different ways so a good
example is date dates in France they are
like we write days and months the other
way around than here so like as a
developer is like when you're starting
writing like international systems it's
a pain in the ass because like those
dudes are like doing things the other
way and so like being able to do
transformation and standardization of
the data the same way whatever the
actual like string is is like super
powerful so instead of saying okay so
I'm gonna get my my string and then I'm
gonna analyze what it is and then
do some transformation what I'm gonna do
is okay get me the dates in my data
assets I don't know if it's JSON I don't
know if it's equal actually I don't care
just get me the dates standardize them
and then do a join on that other data
sources which also hold dates that are
correlated and so as a human you have
the intelligence of being able to say
those two things are correlated but you
don't have to care about how those
things have been implemented in
desparate systems so it like reduces
your time to actually do something
useful drastically so this enables you
to handle variants a lot so tribe
traditional problem in manufacturing and
in data science as well is that it's
super hard to produce the same thing
repeatedly right so in a manufacturing
plant so I worked at some point in like
a tile factory in Europe and so like the
defect rate is something but like huge
like like half of your production just
go to the bin because they don't respect
like the variant standards this is a
huge problem data ensuring the same
thing you have errors like once you get
into big data you have errors all the
time and then like like for some reason
you have one JSON payload that's
different than everything else and
everything breaks so huge pain in the
ass the way with both two layers of
abstraction you're removing that pain
because the mashing of the combination
of that abstraction and machine running
is actually extracting that away and you
don't see it anyone so you build your
thing once and then it works all the
time
how is that related to our customer use
case telecommunication companies what
they have is a network of IOT devices
which have like different versions
different brands different
configurations so here like access
points and routers you can bet that like
all across this geographical area you
probably don't have
probably have ten different brands with
like 15 different configurations and
like the logs that are coming in that
are giving you like the activity are
actually not standardized at all but you
still want your own like one
visualization which aggregates all that
data so this is where what we do comes
in is being able to take all the data
standardize it so that you can build
your resolution on the top of it so in
terms of velocity what does that mean so
we have we've talked about a little bit
like the the time that it takes to
handle different data types we've talked
about the the time that it takes to
handle different data sources but we
haven't really talked about volume and
this like little thing so data volume is
not something that at the log we we
really handle like we still can handle
quite a lot of data because we the Talco
usage that you've seen is like hundreds
of gigabytes a day two terabytes of
their data so it's like still fairly
good the but like abstraction has a cost
so obviously you're not as fast as if
you write your pipeline in C or assembly
if you can in there somebody the the one
over I is about the iteration process
that it takes to to redo the work I like
to each rate on the work so when you
have I was talking earlier at the
beginning out of like you want to ship
things small and shipping fast versus
like a big thing and then try again this
is very related to like batch processing
there's the stream processing so batch
processing obviously has some like good
points like it's like it's usually
higher throughput than stream processing
but like the the problem with batch
processing though is that you having
your file you're transforming it one
first time potentially you have
inventory in the middle any transfer
means like another time and you have an
event event or
transforming another time and then
eventually you get your result but you
only get your result once you've done
your process on all your data the stream
processing is more like hey I get first
element and I work on it get to the next
guy work on the next guy then like put
it out and I can get my first time to
bite very fast so near real-time results
and like too much lower latency than the
batch processing job obviously there's
also hybrids in the middle so like this
like stream with batching in the middle
and you can you can mix and match but
the idea is that the time that you get
your first bite is much for when you do
streaming and that's still important get
back to our cases of telecommunication
super important because hurricane people
die so you need to have data very fast
if you have your data one week later
because your batch streaming is taking
your job is taking a week to run then
your that's too late Megan's like
useless so it's better to have data like
quicker then have it like not when you
need it so in terms of numbers what does
that mean so we've had clients with that
customer we actually reduced by 99
percent the time that it took for them
to actually start using data so it's
quite a lot of time and we also not only
decrease the time it takes for them to
access the data we also improve the
resolution on which they sing the data
by 170 X so that's those numbers are a
little bit outrageous but that means
that they were able to send people to
the right places at the right time which
is super important and on the right you
have like a little bit of statistics on
our machine learning algorithms like how
accurate they are and we like on the
upper 90s like on the accuracy levels so
I think this is it
except for things like quite fast thank
you very much for your time
those are like my social media handles
if you want to ask questions later I'm
up for question now
there are these edges between notes so
you have nodes and then you have edges
between nodes so it's a graph like the
the ensemble of nodes and edges is the
ground
yeah
like we're working on the implementation
so as if we go through it like we've
went through like several iterations of
like what that graph looks like
like the implementation wise but yeah we
do have some like internal ID system to
be able to relate to make the links
between the nodes and edges and like
being able to efficiently go from
parents to children so like a lot of a
transformation that people want to do on
the data is for example hey there's like
two two nodes of data I want to add them
or I want to do a join between two
disparate data sources so the joint is
something that people like to do a lot
so the use case of
one one's in one database you have your
location data in another database you
have your like real-time feed of things
that are coming in and you want to be
able to join those things as they going
in is like something let's super
interesting there so it's like you just
like you have to graph and you merging
them on the fly
[Music]